THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR
THURSDAY AUGUST TWENTY SIXTH IS
HEREBY CALLED ORDER BE ADVISED
ON AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING OF
TODAY'S PROCEED IS BEING MADE
IS ALSO BEING TELEVISED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC ATTENDED THIS
HEARING MUST WEAR A MASK AT ALL
TIMES AND COMPLY WITH GUIDANCE
ON PHYSICAL DISTANCING
ATTENDEES MUST ALSO REFRAIN
FROM CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES.
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THIS
HEARING. VIOLATION OF THESE
RULES BASED SUBJECT AN
INDIVIDUAL TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. HI MISTER
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM BENNETT
FLORA YOUR GIPSON THERE LEE
YEAH MAIENSCHEIN. MATHIS RAMOS
RUBIO ARE HERE WEBER MELCOR WE
HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA HAVE MISTER
MISTER COOLEY I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THE REMOVAL OF ITEMS
SEVEN THE URGENCY REQUEST FOR
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY TWO I
REQUEST THAT WE VOTE ON THAT
ITEM SEPARATE FROM THE OTHERS
OKAY VERY GOOD. ARM THAT WILL
BE THE CASE IS OUR MOTION
REMAINS THE CONSENT AGENDA. MR
MOVER MISTER MATHIS SECONDED BY
OUR MISTER RAMOS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AMID SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL COOLEY. AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM BENNETT FLORA FLORA
I GIPSON GIPSON HIGHLY MAY I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS MATHIS I RAMOS RAMOS I
RUBIO RUBIO BY THE ABUJA PEOPLE
DROP HIGH WEBER. WEBER HI
MOTION PASSES VERY GOOD OF THAT
MOTION IS PASSED- IS OUR MOTION
ON ITEM NUMBER SEVEN THE
URGENCY CLOSE REQUEST FOR S. B.
TWO C. SIX TO HERS FOR MOVE BY
MISTER. GIPSON SECONDED BY MR
LI AMER SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM BENNETT FLORA FLORA
NO GIPSON HI GIPSON HIGHLY HI
BE AYE MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN.
NAAT VOTING MATHIS NOT NO RAMA
RAMOS I READ RUBIO IV PUT HE
PUT A HIGHER WEBER HI MOTION
PASSED BURGER THAT MOST PASSED
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THAT'S
EVERYBODY THIS RULES COMMITTEE
IS ADJOURNED.